et pour en parler nous sommes avec fred
guintrand vice-président de l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
des alpes-maritimes à nice
fred d'intrants qui est également le
patron de plusieurs établissements dans
la ville victor petit à vos côtés
directeur adjoint du développement de ce
qu'il recèle un laboratoire qui a
développé un test salivaire rapides de
dépistage de la cobi 19
bonsoir a trouvé deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous sur l'antenne berthet
france alors confinement partiel et
localisés sains pour les deux prochains
week-ends les commerçants ne sont pas
contents ils l'ont fait savoir
aujourd'hui vous les hôteliers également
les restaurateurs comment vous avez
accueilli cette nouvelle
aujourd'hui plus c'est encore un tour de
10 kg et qui est passé par le
gouvernement on trouve que c'est
évidemment heureux parce que ça c'est
des mois déjà que nous sommes fermés ça
fait des mois que le gouvernement
patauge ce qu'on aurait espéré c'était
une campagne de vaccination qui sont un
peu plus vigoureuse si je puis dire que
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est à
dire que la seule réponse du ministre de
la santé aujourd'hui ça a été de nous
donner 4500 doses de vaccins
supplémentaires et de resserrer un petit
peu plus la vie plus la vis nous ce
qu'on aurait voulu le sait pouvoir avoir
des solutions pour pouvoir vivre vivre
avec le virus parce que malheureusement
on se rend compte que malgré les
confinements malgré les fermetures
malgré les interdictions
le virus continue de se propager
continuent de circuler
donc il va falloir un moment vivre avec
c'est vrai que les commerçants tout à
l'heure à aujourd'hui disait parleurs la
voix de leur représentant qu en gros ça
ne servirait à rien
c'est vrai qu'il faut rappeler quand
même les chiffres un tout peu inquiétant
chez vous métropole lilloise plus de 700
cas positifs pour 100000 habitants plus
de trois fois moins que la moyenne
nationale
vous pensez que ça va servir à rien ces
nouvelles restrictions qu'elle n'était
pas nécessaire toujours été
du côté du gouvernement est en tout cas
on a toujours prôné le fait qu'il
fallait évidemment protéger la vie par
rapport à l'économie
le souci c'est que malgré tout ça on se
rend compte au final qu'il n'y a pas de
succès et qui n'a pas d'avancer alors on
pourrait se demander si nice aujourd'hui
par rapport au fait qu'il y ait plus de
700 personnes positives par rapport à
sanvignes personnes testées ne le soit
pas parce qu'on avait beaucoup de tests
parce que dans la ville de nice on a
testé beaucoup on a été précurseur par
rapport à ça donc peut-être que ça
pourrait expliquer le fait qu'il y ait
beaucoup de tests positifs
la seule chose dont on se rend compte
c'est que malheureusement malgré tout ce
qui s'est passé
rien n'avance rien n'avance on est
encore à la traîne par rapport au vaccin
nous ce qu'on voulait on est enfermé on
s'est dit bon d'écouter avec tous les
vaccinations qui venait lorient on va
pouvoir reprendre une vie normale
voilà malheureusement ce n'est pas le
cas on va faire quoi on ouvrirait comme
ouvrir en septembre et donc
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se posent des questions et dont je
fais partie parce qu'on n'a pas de
visibilité on n'a pas de porte de sortie
nous ce qu'on veut c'est pouvoir
travailler on a été les premiers à
pouvoir affirmer malgré cela on a malgré
les mesures sanitaires très strictes
on a appliqué les protocoles je pense à
la lettre dans la grande majorité des
cas malgré tout ça on est mis sur le
côté et on se rend compte que l'épidémie
continue de progresser
donc on peut être en droit de se poser
la question de se demander si les
restaurants et des cinémas les hôtels
les lieux de vie sont vraiment des
facteurs de propagation du virus parce
qu'on voit que le virus de toute façon
circule toujours
qu'est ce qu'on va faire comme ça est ce
qu'on va continuer encore des années
comme ça à attendre 1 2 3 4 5 6 marion
différent on continue à vivre
je pense qu'il faut trouver les
solutions différentes et la vaccination
en tout cas je pense en fait partie
alors avant la vaccination peut-être les
tests victor petit je me tourne vers
vous déjà on va rebondir sur ce
témoignage et la situation niçoise vous
victor petit qui avait évidemment une
expertise très élevé en la matière des
tests on l'a dit à nice est une des
villes qui a le plus testé c'est un
échec des tests on teste mal en
isolement
comment vous expliquez ça disons que le
test déjà il faut voir que les
technologies ont évolué et qu'elle ils
ont permis petit à petit de faire de
plus en plus de tests donc forcément
quand on teste plus de gens ont peut
être amené à détecter plus de gens
positifs
cependant là où je pense qu'il ya une
sorte d'échec du test on l'a vécu
plusieurs épisodes dans ces échecs c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le test j'entendais
monsieur quintrand évoqué le fait
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de secteurs sont
à l'arrêt en attente de perspectives en
atteinte du vaccin en attente de
solution est typiquement on aurait pu
utiliser les tests certains tests pour
par exemple utiliser et renforcer des
protocoles et des mesures permettant des
activités de reprendre là où il ya eu un
échec à mon sens dans les tests c'est
que la stratégie le triptyque évoquée
par le gouvernement de tester d'isoler
n'a pas été à la hauteur étant donné par
exemple que certaines périodes de
l'année
il fallait des idées les incroyables
pour pouvoir voir les résultats
plus on testera massivement mais avec
des tests qui sont fiables et qui donne
des résultats rapides plus vite en
prendra on pourra prendre des mesures
adéquates et faire redémarrer quelque
part une activité quasi normale au pays
coin mais justement victor petit on va
le préciser a voté ce temps les tests
physiques up sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale désormais depuis début
janvier
on vous a eu un très tôt en interview il
ya déjà plusieurs mois
si je me trompe pas à la rentrée
dernière en septembre dernier à la fin
de l'été pourquoi ça a mis autant de
temps les autorisations pourquoi c'était
aussi compliqué parce que ça aurait
peut-être pu changer la donne justement
pour les restaurants mais aussi milieu
de la culture
bon eh bien il est probable que ce soit
lié au fait que notre notre test qu'on a
développé en lien avec le cnrs donc
quand même une
référence en la matière ne rentre dans
aucune case
enfin ne rentre dans aucune case
préremplie c'est à dire que c'est un
test qui a les performances d'un test
pcr qu'on connaît mais qui donne des
résultats assez rapidement beaucoup plus
rapidement que les tests pcr dont on
parle pourtant tout le temps et dont on
parle notamment dans le cadre du
dépistage des écoles tests salivaires
par rt pcr
le fait qu'on soit avec une technologie
innovante et qu'on ne rentre pas dans
les cases c'est peut-être ce qui a fait
que les autorités ont eu besoin de
beaucoup de temps pour se faire une idée
sur la performance de nos tests sur la
façon dont ils pouvaient utiliser
et puis il ya peut-être aussi le fait
que l'on ait une toute petite société
montpelliéraine qu'on a développé sa au
tout début de la pandémie on est
d'ailleurs ravie qu'aujourd'hui la
salive sont reconnus comme comme
solution viable étant donné qu'on a fait
ce pari là depuis depuis le début de
l'année 2020 tout ça fait je pense notre
taille le fait qu'on rentre dans aucune
case et qu'on soit très innovant a fait
que du coup les pouvoirs publics ont
pris du temps pour avoir un avis sur
notre test et c'est bien dommage parce
que d'autres d'autres pays ont fait le
choix plutôt que la france 2 pariait sur
notre test et ont pu le mettre en place
depuis depuis l'été 2020 et il utilise
aujourd'hui de façon très courante
quand vous entendez ce témoignage des
tests très rapide fiable puisque on en a
souvent parlé ici sur ce plateau et
qu'on voit que ça n'a pas été utilisé
quel est votre conclusion vous on est
trop frileux en france on est trop
conventionnel trop lent quel est votre
avis là-dessus
vous savez je vais je vais essayer
d'être un petit peu tolérante en rapport
au gouvernement parce que
malheureusement ils ont connu une
situation que nous n'avions jamais connu
jusqu'à présent donc là dessus on va
dire qu'on a on peut avoir un petit peu
de tolérance
par contre quand j'entends les propos de
monsieur petit je me dis qu'il ya encore
de l'espoir et qu'on peut encore changer
les choses parce qu'il n'est jamais trop
tard est ce que je me dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si on arrive à tester les
gens d'une façon rapide sur pourquoi ne
pas reprendre une activité on a déjà
fait des tests
il ya eu un essai avec un concert je
crois paris où 500 personnes ont pu
assister à un concert avait été testé
toutes négatives à partir du moment où
on est négatif on n'est pas positif au
virus je pense qu'on peut vivre
normalement
si on arrive à faire à mettre en place
ce système ce procédé est qu'on arrive à
le faire en masse je pense qu'on
pourrait arriver à reprendre à reprendre
une vie normale
et si en tout cas des mesures qu'il faut
essayer parce qu'on se rend compte
malheureusement que les confinements les
interdictions ça ne fonctionne pas
maintenant ça n'a pas de résultats
probants donc je pense qu'il faut vivre
vivre différemment certes mais il faut
vivre avec avec des moyens nouveaux donc
les tests salivaires de l'entreprise de
monsieur petit je pense peuvent en faire
partie alors en attendant ça n'a pas été
retenue concernant nos écoliers puisque
vous le savez les tests salivaires des
buts pour la zone à c'était la grande
négociation aujourd'hui mais pas se dit
zico
alors je précise
la haute autorité de santé qu'il dit
nous poursuivons les échanges avec
l'industriel dans vous mais nous ne
pouvons pas encore rendre d'avis car une
étude de l'assistance publique est en
cours de réalisation et qu'il faut que
nous prenions en compte des résultats de
cette étude c'est ce que précise donc la
directrice de la haute autorité de santé
ses terres le 11 février donc il ya
quelques jours si les données sont
positives nous pourrions l'ajouter à
l'arsenal victor petit vous étiez déçu
de ne pas faire partie justement de cet
arsenal et des tests qui ont été
sélectionnés par l'éducation nationale
vous avez eu un début d'explication
bien sûr que nous étions déçus étant
donné que de toute façon comme je
voulais dit on a fait le pari de la
salive très tôt que notre but est de
justement d'utiliser les tests pour pour
stopper ou pour freiner au maximum cette
pandémie donc du moment qu'on n'utilise
pas notre notre test forcément on est on
est peinée de voir qu'une technologie
qui est performante et qui donne des
résultats rapidement
et donc il peut être utilisé qui peut
être particulièrement adaptées dans
certains contextes n'est pas utilisé
maintenant effectivement la chaise
continue d'explorer
du coup les études périphérie qui
utilisent notre notre test easyq hove
mais là où on est on est embêté c'est
que nous les études cliniques ont été
ont été entamées l'année dernière on a
fourni un certain nombre de résultats
qui nous on a jugés probants que
d'autres états ont jugés probants il
suffisant pour prendre une position
concernant l'utilisation du test
donc je comprends la haute autorité de
santé qui a besoin de prendre
des avis extérieurs qui a besoin de
regarder les tests qui se font mais
aujourd'hui on avait une base
scientifique quand même suffisamment
solides pour pour donner des avis fred
bien trop le mot de la fin pour vous
puisque je rappelle que vous êtes en
quelque sorte le représentant d
hôtellerie niçois des hôteliers niçois
aujourd'hui christian estrosi qui dit ne
venez pas ce n'est pas le le moment
difficile pour le maire de la ville on
imagine en tout cas pour vous des
comptes et ça vous savez je pense que
christian estrosi évidemment est en tout
cas je le pense est un bon maire il veut
protéger les lyssois du mieux qu'il le
peut je voudrais juste clarifier la
situation aujourd'hui à nice huit hôtels
sur dix sont fermés d'accord et sur les
deux hôtels restants qui sont ouverts
sur les 10 ils ont un taux de
remplissage moyen de 15% dont je vous
laisse faire le calcul
je peux vous garantir qu'à l'heure
actuelle en tous les cas ce n'est sans
pas les touristes d'accord qui ont fait
exploser le taux de de positivité au
virus et j'aimerais simplement conclure
si vous me le permettez sur des tests
salivaires notre président a dit que
nous étions en situation de guerre
pas de soucis mais bien en situation de
guerre on prend parfois des décisions
urgentes dans l'urgence des décisions de
guerre et je pense que les tests
salivaires aurait dû être aurait dû être
utilisé même si nous n'avions pas le
recul nécessaire pour savoir si il est y
est plus fiable qu'un test pcr ou
conteste antigénique peu importe je
pense que c'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire
aujourd'hui on préfère fermer une classe
d'école par exemple plutôt que de faire
des tests salivaires et mettre de côté
les élèves qui sont positifs on pourrait
en faire tout autant pour les théâtres
pour les cinémas pour les hôtels pour
les restaurants et pour toutes les
affaires qui font que nous puissions
vivre héros nous remettre à vivre
normalement
voilà merci en tout cas pour ce mot de
la fin revint guintrand victor petit
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france